It's kind of a,
uh,
mediocrity.
You really need to fail to fall out of the limelight long enough to produce
something really strong.
Again.
Totally makes sense.
One of the best things that can happen to a comedian is bombing.
When you bomb that feeling is so bad.
I was describing as like sucking a thousand Dick's in front of your mother.
But the problem is the differences that there's probably someone out there who
would enjoy sucking a thousand Dick's in front of their mother,
but nobody enjoys bombing.
So it's probably worse than that.
But that feeling,
whatever it is,
reignites your appreciation for people's attention span your appreciation for
tightening up your delivery,
your concepts,
figuring out a better way to get them through.
You never want to experience that again.
And some of the greatest moments in my own personal journey of standup have come
from eating shit.
That's where they come from.
You got each,
I mean it's great to do well,
wonderful feels great,
but those eating shit ones,
those are the ones that get you to the notebook.
Again,
those are the ones that reinvigorate you.
Have you spending hours and hours in your hotel room going over sheets of paper
and checking out idea and making sure these concepts connect together in some
sort of a meaningful way and figuring out what tightened things,
cut out the fat.
When you're in this situation right now and you're frantically writing now and,
and,
and you know,
and sort of forced into this,
uh,
element of creativity,
this like,
you're,
you're forced to be hungry again.
I mean,
I wouldn't wish it on you,
but in a way,
do you feel like it's kind of a gift?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You in a way,
you have to accept ultimately that everything is a gift because it's always
about what they call a cognitive reframing,
cognitive reframing,
whatever happens,
you reframe it in such a way that you recognize the value of it.
Um,
and so yeah,
regardless of what happens,
you know,
before my father got murdered,
he had been asking me for an introduction to a known a writer in 1998 and I kept
on thinking,
I am not going to introduce my father to whatnot,
a writer because I know he's going to hit on her.
Okay.
And I wouldn't just going to be mortified to have my dad hitting on,
went on a rider and he'd always talk about how pretty she was.
Any chance I can meet her and,
and,
and to tell the truth,
when I got the word that my father had been murdered by white supremacist in the
mountains of Idaho,
one of my first thoughts was I'm off the hook without Wynona rider thing.
Okay.
And that's cognitive reframing.
And you had to do it all the time.
Glass half full right there.
How long my father,
but you know,
nobody,
none,
none of our relationships are completely perfect all the time.
Right.
It's no way around it.
Yeah.
Well that's again,
the great thing about
unchained writing is that you can express those ideas and that would,
that would be my,
my main concern about any sort of,
uh,
a workshop or support group or any,
any,
any sort of group of like minded peers that wouldn't understand that and that
would want you to limit your language.
I just don't,
it does,
doesn't compute.
Yeah.
And in the platonic world,
yeah,
everybody should kind of get it.
But unless you're ruffling feathers,
even within workshop,
you're not going far enough.
You know,
I loved riding that line and Fight Club,
uh,
where Tyler and Marla have sex for the first time.
And then the most romantic thing that,
that Marla can say is,
I want to have your baby.
So what is the inverse?
So of course Marla turns to him and she says,
I hope I got pregnant because I really want to have your abortion.
And that's the line that the movie studio went around and around.
And even Brad Pitt's head,
do you know,
my mom's going to see this movie.
I don't want her to see this line.
And they shot that scene was so many different substitute lions.
And then finally Fincher wrote the line and Helena Bonham Carter says,
I haven't been fuck like that since grade school.
And at that point 20th century Fox said,
can we switch it back to the abortion?
And so
unless you're always kind of pushing to kind of,
you know,
until you get some push back,
you don't feel like you're pushing hard enough.
And so push back is not a bad thing.
It's just kind of a,
it's proof that you're doing your job.
Does it do
trend?
It's happening now though,
this,
that,
this pushback is coming far quicker than it ever has before.
Is that there's a trend now to,
to limit language and limit creativity and limit the subject matter,
trigger warnings and stop people from,
you know,
it stopped people from experiencing things that might be disturbing.
And I could see both sides of that because on one hand we've got a generation
that has been exposed to so much sensationalistic stuff in order to attain their
attention.
They've really been overloaded with the most extreme versions of everything.
Uh,
in order to get there,
their ticket money or whatever.
Dave really been pounded by so much stimuli.
I could see them kind of really pulling back and wanting to be monastic for the
rest of their lives.
And on the other hand,
I see them as being a
okay
as wanting to sort of counter dominate in order to just create room enough in
the world for their statement.
You know,
they're,
they're moving into a world that's already so occupied by attention getters that
if they can shut some down,
that there might be room for their own expression.
So I kind of see benefit on both sides and in a way to there they're dominating
their teachers,
which is good because it,
it's a way of exploring your own power and,
and figuring out what you can do in the world and that you can have a effect.
You can have agency.
So I don't think it's a totally bad thing.
That's interesting.
The,
the,
the idea that them dominating their teachers is in some way good.
Having the,
well,
it certainly gives you confidence and lets you understand that you can affect
change even if it's meaningless change.
No.
Did you pay attention to what happened at Evergreen state in,
in uh,
Washington?
Yeah.
Did you see when there's a,
for people don't know the story.
It's a,
the Bret Weinstein story where the students decided that there was going to be a
day of absence.
Traditionally it had been where people of color stayed home just so that people
could recognize the important part that they play in the culture in society.
But then they had ramped it up and decided white people are going to have to
stay home now.
And he was like,
that's racist.
And the whole thing went crazy and went haywire and the,
the schools basically falling apart.
Um,
but there was a scene that was filmed where the president of the university was
in,
uh,
president of college was in this auditorium and he was addressing these children
and uh,
they told him to stop moving his hands because it was threatening.
And so he put his hands down,
he put them behind his back and they all started laughing.
And I was like,
wow,
this dumb fuck like this,
this,
this guy's running this university.
And he let them tell him not to move his hands.
Gesturing is you speaking.
And he's like,
what are the ones,
one of the most nonthreatening Beta people on the planet?
And this guy's just giving.
He just wants to keep his job and try to silence this mob,
this angry horde of,
you know,
fucking kids.
They're kids.
But when he listens and puts his hands down,
I probably watched it 10 times.
They all start laughing,
you know,
and just,
I think it just demonstrates how desperately they want a stronger leader.
They don't want,
they don't respect their,
didn't want to learn from somebody who is a college professor and has never
really attained anything in the world.
They just don't want to become another cog in that same kind of,
you know,
we'll,
they want to learn from somebody the respect and whose attainments months,
the day respect,
whose achievements they respect.
Right.
That's probably part of the issue of universities,
right,
is that these professors are so terrified of the reactions of the students,
which is not the place you're supposed to be with a mentor student relationship.
It's not supposed to be that way.
It's not supposed to be.
The mentor desperately needs the student in how you see that sometimes in
private schools with rich kids that they treat their teachers like shit and the
teachers have to bite their tongue and as they,
they have to in all this is not,
it's not,
not,
it's not the normal dynamic that exists with the older wise person and the young
person who's trying to learn from this person.
They deeply respects not that dynamic at all.
It's this old person who's weak and wants to keep their job and is willing to
tailor their own thoughts and ideas to this irrational mob of social justice
warriors.
And that's what we're seeing on campuses now.
You know,
professors calling for censorship and,
and,
and uh,
to stop freedom of expression.
You know,
when I was in college,
my favorite professor,
Roy Halverson,
he was the John Houseman of the journalism school.
He was this old gray eminence and nothing made him happy.
You could never please this,
this,
uh,
this John houseman paper chase guy.
Nothing was good enough.
And,
uh.